tras una de las peores inundaciones de
la historia reciente los habitantes de
igual azul o natal intentan encontrar lo
que queda de sus pertenencias y objetos
de valor entre los escombros de sus
casas
desde hace tres días sólo ha caído
lluvia que viene de acá no sé de dónde
llegó pero estaba lleno de agua por
todas partes lo perdimos todo no podemos
encontrar nada estamos empezando a
construir de nuevo venga que el temporal
que ha dejado cientos de muertos también
ha arrasado con viviendas autos
carreteras e incluso con los
contenedores de uno de los puertos más
activos del país razón por la que el
presidente sigue el rama posa declaró
estado de emergencia y se desplazó al
lugar de los hechos
y realmente veo la gravedad de lo
sucedido lo que les ha ocurrido es muy
difícil y es más duro de lo que hemos
visto al principio
no obstante muchos de los afectados
denuncian que necesitan más ayudas del
gobierno
mi esposa está embarazada tenía miedo de
que tuviera un aborto así que tuve que
hacerlo todo realmente rápido por lo que
ahora estamos hambrientos y no tenemos
nada que comer
no es la primera desgracia a la que se
enfrenta la región el año pasado kuala
zulú natal sufrió protestas e incendios
que se cobraron la vida de al menos
trescientas personas aunque la causa en
esta ocasión es muy diferente según los
expertos el sistema meteorológico de la
costa sudafricana es uno de los más
afectados por la crisis climática y la
previsión para el futuro no es optimista
se estima que estos fenómenos sólo
empeorarán en las próximas décadas